okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i'm
very excited i have a special guest
donovan sharp yes
so donovan i'm sure everyone watching
probably already knows who you are but
if you don't he runs a would you say
men's lifestyle and like red pill
channel yeah yeah it's um
yeah it's it's um uh it started off as
sort of a red pill type channel um it's
it's it's strictly a male channel i talk
about male issues i talk about feminism
masculinity femininity um you know some
of the some of the things that i talk
about would be looked at as
controversial so to speak
but yeah i mean i stand ten toes down on
on my belief system and uh sometimes
it's to my detriment most of the time
it's not so but yeah it's a meds channel
based on you know big gearlive
self-improvement
well i think the whole red pill would be
considered controversial right yes
yes yes yes it's weird because the the
thing is this man
the the the red pill um i've been in the
red pill community since 2014
and it was very different back then so
we're talking about we're talking about
going on eight years
and
the the red pill community has sort of
evolved in a lot of ways and in a lot of
ways it has devolved there are many more
factions so when i first started out uh
in the red pill community um i was just
writing for return of kings that was the
that was the gold standard in terms of
red pill blogs the great and powerful
rouge volley zadeh you guys know him as
bruce v very good friend of mine i've
known him for years
um but after that you know a few years
later i was writing for another website
uh then i decided to try my hand at
youtube and luckily for me i'm pretty
good at it
but the way the the the the red pill has
gone a little bit mainstream and when
when things start to get more eyeballs
you get more attention on what you're
talking about yes
but even more so you get a lot of
hangers on you get people trying to
start their own factions of the red pill
you've got your black pill guys who are
just doom and gloom which you and i were
just talking about off the air um then
you have then then there's this uh
there's this white pill movement which
is quite literally the red pill movement
the only difference is that they just
talk [ __ ] about red bill guys but
a lot of people have tried to sort of
get their hands into this movement for
whatever reason or another some guys
want to do it for money that's fine i'm
not i'm a free market capitalist some
guys really do want to help people when
i came into this community it was just
to tell my story and now we have this
but
you know i think the red pill community
does more it does more good than harm
but it appears to be steering in the
other direction from what i'm saying
anyway
you would say it's like more harmful or
more good like it's steering back to
more harm is that what you're saying
yeah the red pill community there's so
there is so much uh there's so much uh
i don't want to say controversy but
lately i would say over the past two and
a half three years there has been so
much infighting
when i first started out writing for
roosh the only people who really came
after us were feminists anita sarkeesian
uh uh ariana huffington
um
good god man um you know
your the whole gamergate thing with zoey
quinn
all of our detractors were just women
they were just you know feminist
but
i don't know i would say over the last
two like i said two and a half three
years women don't really have to come
after us as much as they used to because
now we're sort of cannibalizing so it
used to be guys from the outside now
it's men in the red pill space you know
pointing at pointing the guns at other
guys in the red pill space that's why i
think it's doing more harm than good
people now when they tune into stuff
like this it's really more about well
who's beefing with who and who's doing
that with what and this and that
not really about the not really about
the message and that's kind of it's sad
but i guess that's the evolution of
things
um though i think that the red pill is
actually very misunderstood yes
yeah well i think um i could say that
because i think a lot of the concepts i
didn't understand what you guys were
saying until like you especially i think
the most misunderstood person is rolo
tomasi yes because his concepts like
yeah you have to watch a lot of his
content to really understand like what
he's talking about right
um so like when i first got in the red
pill i'm like why do they call everyone
beta i'm like
doesn't mean he's a beta in every aspect
of his life
and what i understood like that concept
and then i think alpha just more of
leader right
yeah alpha alpha and beta are
it's there's a lot of shorthand
in the red pill community um alpha is
shorthand for a man who's a a man who's
a good leader he gets the intent i mean
men want to be him women want to be with
him
uh people gravitate toward him and he
also happens to be great with ladies
beta is shorthand for a man who's not so
uh who's not so good with ladies right
maybe a little less confident maybe a
little shorter now there are alpha men
who are short and guys who look like you
know the incredible hulk who are also i
guess you would call beta but alpha and
beta are just
and there are so many no man is totally
alpha or totally beta we're all
variations in between every man strives
to be more alpha than right
i mean i think that i think that goes
without saying but
but
you know there are so many people who
and again just to go back to detractors
they'll they'll use what they'll use
somebody's one beta trait as a
referendum on their overall character
well donovan loses his mind on the air
he's a bit okay fine if that's what you
think that's what you want to think it
is what it is i've never called myself
an alpha male am i an alpha male i don't
know probably not maybe uh maybe a maybe
a glorified beta male who has more than
you know more than the average man
whatever the case may be but it's just
shorthand for you know men who
men who are leaders and betas or are men
who are followers
well and the other thing um
is just when talking about women like i
think women on the outside would not
really understand like what
like i remember i listened to one it was
an entrepreneurs and cars video
and they're like don't date her if she's
too friendly and i'm like damn i like to
chit chat is that like
is that gonna like disqualify is that a
bad thing you know like being friendly
but then like you understand it's more
like girls that are like
super um friendly like tend to talk to
more that means her body count will
probably be higher and i'm like oh i
could i could like understand why they
would think that you know well
it doesn't and if it doesn't apply to
you why does it matter well i'll put it
through this way i think
he used the wrong word women are
supposed to be friendly being friendly
is also being feminine i think what
richard cooper and listen if this is if
this isn't what he meant then fine but i
think what i think what he was trying to
say is that if she is an extroverted
personality if she is the life of the
party if she is the shining star
don't commit to her listen have your fun
with her but don't commit to her for
exactly what you just pointed out pearl
women who are extroverted women who are
always the life of the party women who
are outgoing and entertaining
they thrive on attention and when women
draw attention to themselves they are
going to get more male attention more
male attention equals more male dicks in
you at the end of the day now a lot of
people say well that isn't always the
case well sure it is look where we live
if women get attention women take
advantage of that that attention now
this is not an indictment on the female
species
men and women we can both be very
impulsive women tend to be even more
impulsive when it comes to male
attention
i am never going to be the guy who says
that being a housewife is so much more
exciting than riding the carousel but
there are costs to both right and so
listen just because a girl decides to
listen i don't ever want to get married
i want to i want to uh i want to sleep
around hey listen no one's going to no
one's going to mouth her decision but
then on the back end you can't expect to
be taken seriously as a wife or a
long-term girlfriend if you have that
history so when a girl says well i'm the
life of the party and this and the other
and i've been told this by many girls
that i've slept with okay great you're
the life of the party great we're gonna
have fun for a week or two but
eventually i'm gonna cut you off because
i know you're probably not a good
prospect because
you're you get more attention as a
natural byproduct of your personality
and that's not that's not ragging on her
that's not kicking her to the curb
that's just me saying to myself okay
extroverted women tend to get more
attention than introverted girls not
that introverted girls never cheat
because they do but extroverted girls
get more opportunities and as american
women have shown me throughout my 44
plus years on the earth the more
attention a woman gets the more body she
tends to have
mm-hmm
well that actually goes into our topic
so i'm curious what you think um who do
you think gets um
wifed up first do you think prudes get
wiped up like easily before like the
hose
you know what's weird um
one thing that hoes are and this is why
hoes get wifed up a lot
o's get wifed up a lot because hoes have
perfected
they have perfected the skill of making
a man feel
good sexually right
if a man does not even a man who has the
requisite experience with women to
understand the difference between a hoe
and a prude you don't have to have any
experience you know you know you know
you know which women sleep around you
know which women generally don't
but
what what hoes
hoes have advantages over good girls
that the main advantage is that they
have years and years of practice
perfecting their technique they know how
to look they know what to say they know
what not to say
croods tend to just be honest people and
they're honest because they they can be
all right well how many guys are old i'm
a virgin i mean
if if indeed she is and so
what what um
and so by virtue of their of their
lifestyle
hoes have a lot more practice mimicking
mimicking the behavior of a quality girl
because they've done what doesn't work
right the typical 28 29 year old hoe who
sleeps around she's going to look like a
much better prospect at least in the
short term than the 21 year old who
still lives with parents and went to
catholic or christian school and happens
to still be a virgin because she doesn't
know anything but then you meet that 29
year old and she knows how to look she
knows that actually knows how to feign
submissiveness um who gets who gets
wifed up first croods definitely get
wiped first that doesn't mean that hoes
don't get wiped up more than prudes
because hoes there are more hoes than
prudes but in terms of pecking order
men will have fun with those like i've
had fun with many many hoes but
at the end of the day
if a man understands his worth he's not
going to commit to a hoe he'll have fun
with her maybe make her the side chick
no man of value he wants the 20 year old
who still lives with her parents who
doesn't have high body count
so it's interesting because that is not
what i have seen
and i'm not saying this is no like facts
no data this is just like where's your
stats yeah i got none nothing
um but i see so many single girls in the
church like i know a good amount of like
25 year old virgins which i would say is
like
pretty old would you say that's pretty
old for a virgin 25 how do you know
they're virgins pearl
i guess
you're right i don't know for sure so i
could say one idea is you know they're
lying and telling me that but
um the church that i
like because i'm thinking of when i
lived in milwaukee and the church in
milwaukee was very like tight-knit and
very like
had i put it in each other's business so
like
like
you would like hear things through the
grapevine and so i i would know i think
i think i would know if they would were
lying to me because like stuff just like
gets around there you know you ever live
in like a small town yeah although it's
like the same yeah it's like the same
kind of like yeah
and listen there were there were there
were girls there too but they were
definitely hoes even back in 1992 so
but assuming that you're well let's just
assume for the sake of argument that
these 25 year old women are verifiable
virgins
and all that good stuff yeah yeah and
i've just seen like a lot of virgins
have like a really hard time in dating
and i think part of it is the lack of
like men in the church and maybe
unrealistic standards for those women
and like what to look for in a husband
um but i also don't see like men of
value pursuing them because they would
have to wait to have sex and they just
don't have the time okay
yeah um so let's start with the let's
start with the first thing and i agree
with you um okay
there's a third there's actually a third
factor i'll ask you about uh in just a
second but number one yes their
standards are too high um this doesn't
mean that this doesn't mean that i'm
telling women to lower their standards a
woman can have whatever standard she
wants but what women have to realize is
that
women don't realize that there are not
many high-value men
and
okay so how many 25-year-old virgins are
there well however many 25 year old
virgins there are i can promise you i
can promise you there are even less high
value men
90 of women pearl are competing for 10
of the men
every woman even 25 year old virgins or
women who say they're virgins or women
who don't have high body counts they
have these ridiculous expectations well
i don't want to say ridiculous
expectations they have extremely high
expectations
and at 25
if if you're a virgin at 25
and you still haven't been wifed up then
then either a you're lying about being a
virgin or b this is what i was going to
ask you what do these girls look like
physically are they in decent shape are
they overweight because if you're 25 if
you're a if you're a woman who who has
who is not overweight a woman who's in
shape and a 25 year old virgin either
you're not a virgin or there's something
physically wrong so what's the story
there um
okay i will say
i would say about half of them are like
average size there's a couple that are
like pretty big but i wasn't really
thinking of them because in my head like
there's clearly a reason like obviously
so what happens because they're
overweight right yeah
um the ones that i'm thinking of i would
say are like five to sevens i wouldn't
say any
one girl might be an eight maybe i would
say seven or eight
um but none of them are like crazy hot
to like the eight to ten category
but i would say like pretty to cute does
that make sense well pretty cute is fine
um but but to to a man of value
looking to i guess looking to uh looking
to commit long-term to a woman he's got
to be sexually attracted to her that's
just all there is to it but we're not
looking for the aids nines and tens of
the world i've had enough experience
with i've had enough experiences with
eights nines and tens to understand they
belong to the streets they belong to the
game i said this i'm on episode 810 at
way back in episode 37 way back in 2000
and what 1617 i said the the downsides
to h nines and tens is that they belong
to the game they do not make good wives
they don't make good girlfriends they
don't make good mobs so we we cast those
out so the range that i tell guys to
look for just like you said is the five
to seven range in terms of looks however
if she is in if she is not overweight
and when i say oh when i say not
overweight i'm talking about a girl
who's in who who is in good shape not
decent because a lot of girls say well
she kind of has a decent weight or she's
an average size the average woman in
this country weighs 165 pounds that's
fat what at what height
i'm just thinking like i'm thinking of
these girls so i'm just talking about
if they're five five to five six hundred
and sixty five pounds
i would say
they're like
150 or lower
let me ask you let me ask it to you this
way maybe maybe this is a better answer
would a guy like me
say that those girls are overweight
um
i'd say one for like i would say one of
them you would okay but i would say the
rest no
okay so so what's the problem with them
then if they're 25 they're not
overweight but they are still virgins
it has to be it must be the expectations
and i'll tell you this a lot of girls um
a lot of girls rightfully wait until
they're trying to wait until marriage to
be in a relationship so they start
dating a guy the guy wants to have sex
with him and guess what if i'm a
high-value guy and i'm dating a girl who
is supposedly a virgin guess what i'm
going to try to take her virginity you
want to know why because i want to know
she's i want to know if she's really a
hoe if a girl says i'm a virgin and i
sleep with on the first date clearly not
a virgin
but but the best way for a man to [ __ ]
test a woman is to try to sleep with her
on the first date because if you sleep
with her on the first date you know she
has slept with other men on the first
date which means she is not worthy of
commitment so now we get that out of the
way so now virginal girls i guess at
your former church will say well i date
guys but then they dump me
because i'm not having sex with them if
a guy is dumping you because he's not
having sex with you that is a man who's
not looking for anything serious if a
man is looking for something serious
with a woman long-term partnership or a
long-term relationship or marriage with
children and he knows you're virgin
you're telling him no i'm not going to
have sex with you until we are married
or in a relationship and he bounces
he didn't want to be in a relationship
anyway and that's not the kind of guy
you want to be with so then it goes back
then it really just goes back to the
girl so a lot of these girls are saying
well he dumped me because i'm not i'm
not having sex with him now there's this
other quandary well what if i stay with
him but then he starts sleeping with
other girls well guess what now you have
a choice to make you can either a
understand that it's just sex for him
and that he's just gonna get his rocks
off and you can wait around or b
lower your standards because men who are
able to have sex with girls are going to
be way higher value than men who
generally cannot men don't want the
average guy they want the above average
guy and one of them and the price to be
paid for it above average to a high
level elite high value guy is
understanding that he is going to stick
his sausage in other chicks
oh i disagree with that actually of
course you do i wouldn't i wouldn't
imagine i wouldn't imagine that any
woman would ever outwardly agree with
that but what women no i think i think
my dad just gave me too high of
standards he was like too good of a dad
and a father to be honest oh okay yeah
like he would he would he would never in
a million he doesn't drink he doesn't
have social media he would never in a
million years
yeah i know no one in the meadow sphere
believes me but
well i mean listen i mean you know
you're i mean you seem to be you seem to
be you know a decent i mean you're not
overweight you're you know you're decent
looking i think you have a boyfriend so
but but when and and this isn't and i
would say this is not really a
generational thing
but the difference between
how can i put this
how can i put this the difference
between a man who loves a woman and a
man who doesn't is a man who really
really loves his girlfriend or wife he's
not going to let her find out that he's
smashing other chicks a lot of people
disagree with this they're like oh my
god i can't believe it if you love her
you would never step out on her no
that's that's not the case at all if you
love a woman you will never let her find
out that you're stepping out on her this
is just this this is the male condition
now some people would say well what if
she sleeps with other guys well
then at that point the relationship is
over because when a woman sleep when
when when when a man's wife cheats on
her
men don't take back their cheating wives
at nearly the rate that women take back
their cheating husbands why because
inherently women know that sex is just
physical to men it doesn't mean that
they're okay with it doesn't mean that
it's not going to hurt but they
understand okay
here's here's the thing
the first question and i've been cheated
on many times the first question i ask
her is is a stick bigger than mine right
as men were prideful creatures but i've
also been caught cheating and the first
pearl is always
do you love her and the answer is always
no i don't love her yes
and she's throwing [ __ ] and this and
that any other
but women know that sex is not about
feelings for men that doesn't mean it
doesn't hurt when they find out their
man steps out
but they understand listen as long as
you're not getting anybody pregnant i
don't see it smell it taste it let me
find out about it don't [ __ ] her at my
house don't get anybody pregnant don't
let me catch you then see no evil here
no eagle
really so you don't think that's selfish
yeah it's very selfish okay
um and you don't think like some people
just have character and like choose not
to do that
not sticking your dick in other chicks
has nothing to do with character
what do you mean
like you realize like if you're if
you're hooking up with other girls
even if you don't um even if you use a
condom like you can still give your wife
an sti
um and so you don't you don't think
that's like pretty selfish yeah that's
very selfish yeah that's very selfish
yeah okay um yeah listen it's very
selfish um but i would also i mean yeah
it's it's very selfish but it is what it
is
what what what we have to understand is
that i don't want to use the all's fair
in love and war but we are driven by
biology we as humans what the difference
between and i'll give you a perfect
example
a lion out in the jungle he meets with
one lioness is it wrong for him to mate
with another lioness of course not
that's his pride that his his objective
is to spread his genetic material well
what's the difference between us and
lions or other wild animals it's our
ability to reason
it's it's the human condition that tells
us that it's wrong that it's wrong to
sleep with other people now here's the
thing now a lot of people say okay well
donovan well what if a woman sleeps
sleeps with other people i'll put it to
you this way
one lioness
a lion okay propagates five lionesses
right that's his harem one lioness does
not take uh semen loads from five
different lions they're loyal to one
lion this is not this this is the
natural order of things it's just not
something they do and there's no reason
they're they're acting on blind instinct
and biology here's another thing if uh
if one alpha lion defeats another alpha
lion what does he do with the cubs that
are not biologically his pearl
doesn't kill them i feel like i've heard
kevin samuels say this right yeah okay
no i'm just i think i've heard this
example before yeah
he he he kills the cubs is it okay with
the mom no but what is she gonna do
about it like go to another pride the
point is is that a stud horse
a stud horses used to impregnate many
mares one mare doesn't take the take the
the sperm of many of many horses that's
just not the way it is but the reason
why we say cheating we call it cheating
with men we call that wrong is our
ability to reason there are feelings
involved right does that make it right
or wrong
i don't think that matters the the fact
of the matter is is that we as men
we are genetically designed to reproduce
until the day we die yes the quality of
our sperm goes down when we're over 50
or 60 whatever the case may be but women
can only give birth to a finite number
of people in a finite amount of time we
as men we can procreate forever
and
i mean that's why i take morals out of
the reproduction thing because that's
just it's it's it's a human condition
that's so interesting so do you in in
your like world view or like the way you
look at it would you say that
all men cheat like regard like over um
let's say like over a certain income
maybe
would you say a hundred percent cheat
um men don't cheat they exercise options
okay yeah i know you say like they don't
cheat they have sex but you understand
what i'm asking right so then so the
right so so i'll actually put it to you
this way and i don't there's no science
to this but but
it's just like your general some stuff
is just like what you feel or like well
no that's not what i feel this is this
is what happens a man who is worth let's
just say what's the man who's worth ten
figures that's a billion dollars a man
who's worth ten figures can have his
wife and a side piece living in the same
house right oh yeah oh yeah life inside
me yeah because the girls will be fine
with it yeah well there you go because
it is not worth if you're worth if
you're worth a million dollars you can
have a wife and a side piece that she
knows about but you can't but she can't
be living with you right right okay she
knows about uh she knows about uh
brianna that you bang down in houston
every other month or whatever she's cool
that whatever the case may be her kids
are taken care of it's all good
if you're making a hundred thousand
dollars if you're worth a hundred
thousand dollars you can have a side
piece but your girl can't know about it
and this is all this is all dependent on
the woman because if you're worth a
hundred thousand dollars a woman is not
going to a woman is not going to stay
around if you're banging other chicks
why
because there are more men who are worth
a hundred thousand dollars than men who
are worth a million dollars so yeah the
the the the woman who was with the man
who's worth a million dollars
okay so he's got a side piece and i know
about it but guess what my guy is a top
half percenter what am i going to do
leave him and find another millionaire
same with the millionaire the
billionaire wife well okay so diana's
living in another wing of the house what
am i going to do find another billion
dollar man
so what it really could be leave and
take half
yeah
well listen listen check this out
they'll they'll even take half but half
of a billion dollars is 500 million and
get this okay so she leaves and takes
half what is she going to do go date
another billionaire no because at that
point i mean
well jeff bezos his wife married a
teacher yeah
you made my point for me yeah yeah
awesome so jeff bezos's wife mckenzie
bezos upgraded from the richest man on
earth to a teacher yeah do you think
it's do you think it's all about like
money when it comes to like marriage and
like happiness and a relationship
do i think it's all about money um
you don't think like character has
anything to do with it
a character does have character has a
lot to do with it but i'm not talking
about moral character
um
i'll put it to you this way
a woman is not going if if a man does
not make as much of a does not make as
much as his woman
she can't respect him she will want to
respect him so bad but if you are not
the breadwinner you are not going to
have the respect and subsequent love
from the woman we would love to think
women women would love to think that
they could really truly love a man
who who makes less than she does but you
guys are not nor should you be
biologically hardwired to like a man
whose net worth i guess is lower than
yours you don't want a man to be
financially dependent upon you pearl i
know this to be true look who your
father is look who your mother is even
if you come from a broken home it is in
it's in a woman's brain and women women
try this all the time
ceo at a whatever 500 company she'll try
to date the guy from jiffy lube and
she'll give it the old college try
can't respect it because he only makes
50 dollars a year so yes money is
important when it comes to a woman's
respect for you yes there are varying
degrees depending upon depending upon
whatever situation but women do not want
men to be financially dependent upon
they just don't uh do you think that it
matters like where the person got there
like do you think sorry doesn't it
no so do you think like a rapper is on
the same level as like uh
i actually totally disagree
if a rapper's worth a billion dollars
and the ceo is worth a billion dollars
what's the difference
um you know what i'll put it down
well because a rapper that's worth a
billion typically didn't get that money
from rap right like typically
okay
hold on you just move the goal post all
right
post so so so listen i'll i'll i'll
actually tell this here's the dichotomy
ceo of a fortune 500 company he's worth
50 million dollars
drug lord worth 50 million okay yeah
that's fine that's fine yeah women don't
give a [ __ ] women do not care women
don't listen man
women don't care how you got there they
care that you're there whether you're a
ceo of a fortune 500 company or you're a
drug or you're a colombian drug lord yes
there are costs and benefits to the ceo
yes there are costs and benefits to the
drug lord but women don't listen how
many men on this earth are worth 50
million dollars not that many so if a
woman has a chance to actually be with a
man who's worth 50 million dollars she's
not going to care where it came from
that doesn't make her that doesn't mean
she's morally bankrupt she's looking at
the dog she's thinking about the long
term hey okay so
my husband is a colombian drug lord my
kids are going to be fun
pardon me my kids are going to be fine
i'm never going to have to want for
anything again he's got wills estates
and trusts it's the same thing on the
other side men we don't care how a girl
got physically fit right we hear that
she's physically fit so when you say hey
is money the only factor when it comes
to a woman so you don't you don't care
about life well sorry sorry is money the
only factor it's not the only factor but
it's the biggest one just like for us
looks is the biggest factor i don't care
how you got there
as long as you're there
you don't care about like a because i've
heard there are studies that men um when
they see like fake boobs they register
like that girl more as someone they
would hook up with and not date that's
[ __ ]
studies are [ __ ] man those studies
are [ __ ] there are many women who
there there are many wives who have fake
tits so it's just you know whatever and
again it's like like the whole fake tits
thing right there are many different
kinds of fake tits but
large breasts that uh that's a signal of
fertility fertility is sexually
attractive to men so oh wait a minute
she has the she has the best breasts
i've ever seen but they're fake so no a
man is turned on by what he sees it
doesn't matter just like the drug lord
oh he got his 50 million dollars pushing
cocaine i don't know no she's going to
want to be with that dude because it's
worth freaking large same with the guy
oh wow she's got great breasts he gets
oh these are fake oh all of a sudden now
i can't get hard because i know our tits
are fake that's [ __ ] it doesn't
matter how they got there as long as
they're so actually i disagree with you
um i think that like there are levels to
like how men got their money and there
are some that are like women
seek after more than others
um i don't have it completely mapped out
as to like which ones i think are at the
top and at the bottom
but like i think um
like i'll give you an example like
like push iced freedom like those
rappers that are like big i think a lot
of like girls that like i know wouldn't
want to date them because of the way
they like carry themselves you're so
cute
no i'm serious you're you're serious but
you don't you you don't see this is the
thing
like oh you think hold on let me finish
let me finish think about who your
father is okay because of who your
father is and his net worth you have
this crazy idea that there are people
worth millions of dollars all over the
world no i don't
well i said i see my doctor
but see that's just the thing that's why
women thank you that's why women don't
care how they got there a woman is not
going to she's not if let's just say a
woman knows a guy is worth 50 million
dollars it does not you can tell me all
you now you personally you'll care where
it comes from because your dad has you
know he's you know he's got money but
you are the exception to the rule women
know women inherently know that there
are not many men out here worth eight or
seven and eight figures i don't care how
he got the money listen
oh it's blood money i can't accept this
listen if
if they're in a house that's completely
paid for and she's driving a she's
driving a jaguar whatever the case may
be she does not care nor should she do
you think maybe in like the hind brain
sort of way it's because of
like i think like deep down like we know
that none of those rappers would offer
like 90 of the girls they talk to
commitment
i'm just curious
well i don't know what that has to do
with a woman choosing a rapper to try to
commit to
um i mean don't you think girls go after
guys they can attain or try to
like what like what's attainable for a
girl
i don't know like
um
sorry i didn't really think this through
a little bit um so like let's say
i have a friend um and she's had like
rappers in her dms like i would put her
at maybe a seven or an eight okay um
and i would say she's like 130 she's
like athletic though so 130 140 but like
you know athletic build
um but like she's never responded or she
tells me she doesn't respond to them i
should say she could be lying but let's
assume she's telling me the truth and to
me it's because like that type of
lifestyle like what are the odds he
would commit to her that's very true but
why are rappers sliding into her dms
she's hot
she's hot and what and how do we know
she's hot
um you'd have to take my word i don't
know
the reason we know she's hot is because
that's the kind that's she's posting
that stuff on instagram
okay oh
okay okay yeah you get it rappers listen
check this out rappers are not going to
they're not sliding into the dms of
soccer moms who aren't posting booty
pics they're not sliding into the dms of
girls see rappers like like like men
they're not stupid they're not going to
shoot their shot at someone who does not
appear to want to shoot
so your friend is bragging well i got
these rappers and all this sliding into
my dms trust and believe there are
things she is doing on her instagram
that is enticing them to slide into her
dms so she can say she doesn't want that
kind of life and non-commitment all she
wants to and she might be telling the
truth but but just according to what
you're telling me about her there
appears to be precious little evidence
of this and listen she likes the fact
that guys who are worth a lot of money
or slide into her dms like that's
exciting for her i guess that may be
that maybe why she's proud of it but you
have to think about
a funny thing happens when you advertise
you get customers if you're putting out
those kinds of vibes rappers are not
stupid they're not they're not hit up
girls that are that that are holding up
a
a rosary nah they're sliding into
i could see that
um
hold on i actually
had a list of okay so the next thing i
want to talk about is female like so
when i first got into the red pill it
was very confusing
because i think that some of the
i don't want to say this is advice for
females but if you're a female like
listening to the red pill it's very
confusing because first they tell you
they don't want a girl with a high body
count i understand that not gonna like
fine i agree with that okay
then but then they also say like if a
girl doesn't sleep with you by the third
date to move on right and to me i'm like
you could do three dates in a week like
how are you gonna how are you gonna have
a girl that keeps a low body count if
she's sleeping with you with three dates
like that's so fast well this is i've
heard it's because
i've been in a relationship for a little
bit so it could have just been like
i don't know maybe i haven't been in
like the dating scene long enough but
uh yeah that was my thought process
no no this is this is something this is
something we've gotten for a while man
um
so
the question you're asking is okay you
red pill guys don't want girls with a
high body count but then
if she's not banging after the third
date we move on so or they'll say well
listen you you don't want girls with a
high body count yet you're out here
smashing all these girls and adding to
their body count i i understand sorry
the second part because obviously like
you're gonna have sex with a girl that
you would never date i 100 i just went
to a pickup event where like guys are
like taught how to get laid it was like
the video's dropping this week you
should react to it and
um it's going to be fire guaranteed all
right all right
but like they like and i talked to these
guys because these are guys that take
home like three four girls a week yeah
and they tell me like there's a type of
girl they would take home but never be
seen in public yes so i i 100 understand
like there's a difference i understand
having sex is different for men and for
women i'm just asking like if a girl
wants to be taken seriously by that type
of guy
and you tell those type of guys don't
leave if she doesn't have sex by the
third date like it just seems like that
advice is counter-intuitive does that
make sense it makes perfect sense okay
and here's here's here's where girl now
here's where girls go wrong right okay
let's just say let's just say for the
sake of argument one of your 25 year old
virginal friends at your former church
in wisconsin let's just say she's a
virgin she's a good shape she's pretty
she needs a dude like me right i take
her out on the first date she doesn't
give it up second date she doesn't give
it up third date she doesn't give it up
now
at that point we would advise men to
leave you want to know why we advise men
to leave because we know that most girls
sleep around okay okay most girls sleep
around so if a girl
and
i don't
we know most girls sleep around we can
dude we can look at a girl dude by the
third date just by the thing she tells
us i have a course called woman ease you
can you can tell pretty quickly i've
reacted you've seen them i've reacted
i've seen yeah these are actually pretty
good and so we if a girl we know sleeps
around doesn't give it up after the
third date we're scooting because we
know she's giving it up to other guys or
she has in the past you're trying to get
sticker price for for for because
because then she's not attracted to you
it's the genuine desire there you go
there it is but here's the thing here's
the thing let's say that i'm out on
three straight dates with your with your
25 year old virginal friend well guess
what
if she's out with a guy like me she
really likes me and if and listen i've
tried three times she's like look
donovan i really like you but i'm not
having sex with you until we're in a
relationship if after that she can she
sends me good morning texts hey i'm
thinking about you hey let's do
something fun if she continues to give
me what i call plan a attention which
means there are no other guys then guess
what at that point i'm thinking okay
this girl she claims she's a virgin
there are no other guys around her i
don't see any thirst trapped pictures on
instagram or the case may be she's hit
me up all the time she's always over at
my place
i think i'll keep her around for a
little while that's the difference so so
when we tell guys to dip after the third
date she doesn't give it up we're
talking about we're talking about girls
who we know are hoes who have given it
up on first dates plenty of times listen
we know you're 38 years old and and now
you know you're worth but guess what i'm
not about to i'm not about to pay that
price right
um so yeah that's that that's the
difference that's the difference between
the virginal girl and the girl because
we know most women sleep around and if
she doesn't sleep if you have the third
day she's not into you player
um so the next question i had was
so then different scenario right and
this is something i see in the church
often
so there's a girl that has i wouldn't
say like she's not a virgin but she has
a low body count um but she gets over a
certain age so let's say but she still
has a low ball like some of these girls
they tell me right and i do think this
is a problem because i think there's not
enough men in the church i think that's
one problem and a lot of times the
churches tell you not to date outside of
your church
but when there's three girls to so i
that's definitely like one of the
reasons this is a thing and the church
has driven out men like that's why
they're yeah so yeah that's another
conversation but yeah yeah different
different day but actually rolo tomasi
ruins church a little bit this is a
whole different conversation he made me
like
because i'm going to talk anyway he um
because because
he pointed out these
things that i thought about but i
couldn't articulate like why like like
this something didn't feel right because
there would be these chastity speakers
that would come to our school because i
went to catholic school for 12 years
this is getting um this is the first
public school i've ever been to um
and i'm getting my masters right now
which i know is like the what's the
little
like that i'm a phd yeah yeah yeah
for fun though i wanted to play um
semi-pro volleyball so i got my masters
so i could do it
but anyways he
and they would these chastity speakers
would come to our school and then
basically the girl would be like yeah i
got ran through in high school but like
didn't say it like that she wouldn't say
it like that
okay like obviously okay this is it
would be it would be
she would say it nicely right she would
not say i got ran through she would say
i was still lost i was so broken i was
right right yeah but then
but then i like stopped doing that stuff
and i found my husband and i remember
thinking like so you're going to tell us
all to wait when you did all that
right like
oh that's why but but here's here's the
thing
and this is the this is and this is a
skill that women have to acquire
it is very very very very difficult for
a woman with a high body count to hide
her body count even if she doesn't tell
and again if you're with a man who knows
his [ __ ] if you're the man who knows
this [ __ ] you can't hide your body count
you just can't do it because dude i've
slept dude i've slept with so many girls
i know i know all the signs oh my god
it's ridiculous and so when i meet and
this is the thing this actually happened
when i first met dev so when devon and i
first started dating i was sleeping with
other people and she was sleeping with
other people we were both very open
about that
well one of the guys one of the guys
that she liked she liked another guy i
guess
she liked to i forgot who he was
but for whatever reason he dropped out
of her rotation and then another guy and
then there was some drama with with with
someone else and she was spending most
of her time with me but she was thinking
to her she was like why is it like i'm
tired of this cycle and well me and she
knew i was not even sure but i was like
well the reason why is because you do x
y and z and she's like you know what
she's like i'm 39 years old she's like i
really i'm tired of doing this
roundabout so you'd only been divorced
for six and in months of dating she was
already
she devin got married at 21 and got
divorced when she got divorced she was
39 so she was married for 18 years so
she had relationship skills she just
didn't know how to use them because she
was just kind of out there and so she
says look you're mr red pill whatever
whatever teach me train me and so that's
that's kind of how that's kind of how
that started all of that said devin i
knew that i knew that devin had not been
because most girls are on the carousel
through their 20s and 30s
devin was married from 21 to 39 yeah she
was having her fun after the divorce but
i met her five to six months after that
so i mean how high could her body count
have been i'll never know i don't care
the point is is that i recognized okay
this woman is 39 years old and i'm not
catching any hoe vibes from her the
reason why i wasn't catching any hoe
vibes is because she'd been married for
almost two decades so she didn't really
she didn't move and act and she didn't
move and act in such a way that now who
knows maybe she was a master of disguise
why do you always say she was a hoe on
your channel well because when i well
because when i met her that's what she
was okay she was you kidding me oh my
god of course she was
she's like well just so you know i'm
dating this guy i'm like hey listen man
like it's it's all fun and games it
didn't didn't hurt my feelings because
we were we were two consenting adults so
yeah when devin when i met deb she was
being oh and she'll she'll say as much
terms of endearment it is what it is but
but when you're but if i had met let's
just say devin didn't get married at 21.
got ran through her 20s and 30s
pardon me and i see her at the
baskin-robbins and we start talking
again
it would have dude honestly it would
have taken me a half a day to figure out
okay this [ __ ] has been ran through
like your girl that you're like your
girl the chastity now there are some
women there are some women who have
mastered the art
of hiding their body count in other
words
they have mastered the they have
mastered the traits that don't give away
that they've been ran through it's very
very difficult to do and if you're with
a guy who really knows what he's doing a
guy with a lot of experience it's not
easy to get one over on him i can't
imagine that it's happened too often but
the girl just like you said who got ran
through but found her husband i can
promise you her husband probably was not
that experienced that's probably why she
was well well i think that's why like
when he described like the guys in the
church being like beta and being like
yeah then they'll like take on the i'm
like oh my god like
like
it's not it's not that many of the
church it's not that men in the church
are beta it's just that men in the
church aren't taught
that you it says in the bible that man
leads the household but that's not what
they're teaching in church because dude
if you ever put any of my videos my team
videos in a church oh my god what is
this blasphemy and da da da da listen
man the bible is as red pill as any book
that that has ever been written the
problem is is that the church is a
business and if you're not if you're not
putting out the message that people want
to hear the pretty lies instead of the
ugly truth you're not going to get as
many parishioners mm-hmm
well and
i don't know yeah rolo ruins church for
me i'm not even gonna lie like once i
i'm not even gonna like
once i saw it i couldn't see it no
and i'm like oh my gosh um okay but so
so what i was going to say though is i
see girls with you know if again they
could be lying but let's just assume for
sure
yeah
let's say less than five bodies right
okay but then they get to a certain age
and they're used to like making a guy
wait right like months whatever but they
get to a certain age and even though
they have a low body count it doesn't
really matter anymore because they're
past a certain age that's right that
makes sense that makes perfect sense so
like and i feel like that stuff isn't
really like taught to women we're like
and that's where i see hoes get wiped up
faster that's right
very good
because and that's like the bad dating
advice that i think i see in the church
yes yes because yeah it's wacky listen
case and i don't like to bring in uh
celebrities or exceptions to the rule
but look at lolo jones lolo jones is
beautiful she's a 40 year old virgin
nobody wants to take yes
nobody wants to take the no one wants to
take the virginity of a 40 year old we
want to we want to take the virginity of
a 20 year old a woman in their 20s
nobody like rocky took adrian's
virginity when adrian was 31. good for
rocky and that was of course just the
story but but yeah like your virginity
is sacred but once you get past a
certain age it's like okay
like i mean is it really a hymen when
you're 35 years old or yeah i mean like
what are we doing here but yeah you're
right
and i think a lot of those girls um
like the
they're used to being able to like hold
out for a guy because they were young
before and maybe they don't especially
in the church there aren't a lot of guys
a lot of the time
so they're used to like when they find a
guy they like like making him wait and
him being willing to oh but like this is
and my church that i went to isn't as
crazy like you see a lot of like there's
not a lot of like the single mom
syndrome that like i didn't really see
that in my church i i know that's common
it's common in black churches
i see single women but not single moms
that's what i see in my church oh i'm
with you i'm with you yeah the thing
about oh god churches are just
churches are like it's it's it's it's
kind of an anomaly but churches are
every bit as responsible for the
neutering of men as feminism is man it's
it's sad to see but but that's how it is
i mean listen i'm all about chastity and
this and that and a third but and here's
the thing let's go back to your church
in wisconsin let's just take that
scenario i haven't slept with your 25
year old virginal friend yet right
if i see that she really likes me i'm 44
she's 25 i'm like okay
like nobody has supposedly smashed this
girl
i'm not picking up any whole vibe she's
always she's always letting me know
what's up she's always over here blah
blah blah blah
now i'm not gonna i'll wait for sex from
her but if i do smash other girls i'm
not gonna let her find out and the
reason why i'm not gonna let her find
out is because i'm serious about a
relationship i am not about i am not
about to scare i'm not about to scare
off now she might have her suspicions
but
i'm i'm i mean i'm really good at hiding
my uh my extracurricular activities
hopefully
no she's in there um but uh but yeah if
if if if a girl is worth it to me
i'm not going to wait for sex because
i'm trying to [ __ ] but i'm not i don't
want to mess this up so if i am smashing
other girls there's no way i'm letting
her know about it
okay
so okay that i'm gonna give you four
different scenarios okay that's a girl
let's say let's say you had a daughter
right he had four daughters four
yeah yeah god was just like
now one of your daughters is a 30 year
old single mom okay one of your
daughters is all they're twins a 30 year
old um let's say she's slept with less
than like low body count whatever you
put that as less than five listen to
like whatever you know that your
definition one of them is a 16 year old
virgin
and one
let's do let's do 20 now let's just do
three let's just do three oh no one one
young but with a high body count okay so
i've got twin 30 year olds one is a
single mom one has a body count of less
than five i've got to say can i can i
make the 30 year old young
sorry yeah i'm sorry so like make make
the twins one low body count one high
body account becomes one
yeah yeah single mom at 30. okay and
then a virgin and like what would you
how would you tell them because i think
that dating advice should be different
based on like for different girls
absolutely and let's give them all let's
give them all sixes and that's why i
think women's dating advice is so bad
because they give you advice as if
you're an eight nine or ten yeah and i
don't think all girls are
right and this in large part is the
reason why your 25 year old virginal
friends who are still in good shape are
still single and virgins because they're
they're not eights nines and tens okay
so to my um to my to my 30 year old uh
single mom uh my advice to good god
what's her name to michelle
yeah um all right michelle um so you're
a single mom
uh you've had two you've had two kids by
uh by two different dudes uh and you're
really really and you're looking for a
good relationship what i would tell
michelle is this i love this
she can't she can't get the dad's back
just you know sorry didn't mean to
interrupt you i don't know
that's not an option okay no no no i
totally i got you okay but i would be
very i'd be like michelle you know i
love you i would do anything for you but
you're gonna have to understand that
you're gonna have to set your sights a
little bit lower because the man that
you want the men that you're looking for
are not looking for you okay they're
looking they're looking for girls like
your sister okay your sister is 16 years
old and she's still a virgin
you had a pregnancy scare when you were
16 and now look at you you're listen i
love you and i know this is not gonna
i know this is hard to hear and i'm not
telling you that there's no hope you
just need to understand that the kind of
guys you're looking for are not looking
for you i tell you this out of love
because i don't want you to be
disappointed
would you rather be i mean would you
rather be a single mom forever or would
you rather just get what get what you
can get
uh to the 30 year old who or the 25 year
old with a low body count
um what i would advise her to do is i
would say uh let's say michelle and
let's see
debbie deborah i'd say deborah you need
to move back in with me and your mother
why dad
because the men that you're looking for
do not commit to women who live alone
why not because they know that women who
live alone get ran through if you're
living with us they know you're not
getting ran through because i'm in this
[ __ ]
trust me when i tell you that if they
find out yeah okay i'm 25 i haven't had
many bodies but i still live with my
parents but i don't want to be a loser
no no no no no debbie if you listen if
you had a brother and he were 25 and
live with us he would be a [ __ ] loser
because he's a man and men are held at
higher standards well you're not holding
me to a high standard no that's exactly
why i'm having you live with me because
when you're out there in the real world
debbie there's going to be temptations
you have eyes there are guys you want to
sleep with but you have to look at the
long term so listen i'm going to give
you a choice if you want a chance to
have a good relationship with a high
value man you need to move in with us
until you're married and free rent
free
listen dude listen debbie will feed you
will
you you can drive one of our cars
i mean like that that's that's a good
deal you guys looking for a kid
oh my god no see i don't have any kids
that i know of but
that's what now for my 16 year old
virginal girl
okay um let's call her let's call her
lacey
lacy so what's gonna happen when you
turn 18 years old i'm going to lock your
door from the ethno um what i would
advise her to do
is i'll say lacy i'm going to give you
i'm going to give you two choices
you can either go to community college
and you're going to go to a local
community college you're going to live
with us okay
now it depends on what she wants out of
life do you want to get married lacie
well of course i do okay do you want to
be married to to to to a bum somebody
who lives in a trailer well of course
not dad okay
so what kind of man are you looking for
well i'm going to be tall dark handsome
and rich okay that can happen
but i'll tell you how it cannot happen i
said you have all the advantages now
you're young you're pretty you're a
virgin
if you want the best chance at that you
need to live with us until you're
married again just like i told you just
like i told debbie
listen free rent we'll pay all the bills
we'll let you drive your own car if you
want to do vocational school if you want
to go take a course here somewhere we'll
completely finance it
you can stay here until you're married
that's what i would tell her your oldest
sister michelle
can michelle
can michelle live with us now michelle's
got two kids that [ __ ] is on her own
i'll tell your sister i said that and
that's what i would that's what that's
wait so would you tell her because this
is another analysis i have okay from
what i've seen i've seen girls that have
a low body count have better outcomes
than girls that have zero like a virgins
in terms of the guys they can get
okay um would you say so for the virgin
would you tell her to wait till she's
married or until she finds a guy of
value
if if a woman who is a virgin is not
getting the same outcomes as the girl
with the five body count that means the
girl with the virgin is overweight
that's the only
no
no
from what i've seen from what i'll say
listen then you're dealing with the
exceptions to the rule girls who are in
good shape who are virgins get dude they
get snatched up very quickly they're
they're
that's just the way of it these girls
get found like these girls get found so
if if if a girl is in decent shape and
she claims she's a virgin but she isn't
getting the same outcomes and there's a
problem with her strategy maybe she's
really like an undercover hoe uh maybe
she had
something is going on with her now that
doesn't mean that that she can't be the
exception to the rule but the exception
i've found it's more like the church
like i think the church keeps them
single that's like what i found or
whatever how do you say that oh that's
interesting
because they tell girls not to date
outside the church
partially okay i think that's one like
um the girl i'm thinking of and she
would be a great wife like she has i put
i'd put it she's 25 i put her in a seven
or eight i'd say like if kevin samuels
might put her at adjustable six i think
most of the world would put her at nate
okay
um
and
what's the dress up
the small
is your dress size i don't know like
five seven
she's small like she's not like yeah i
don't i don't know how much because i'm
six foot
so like the weight
yeah yeah so like the i don't know what
like normal girls weigh because like
300 pounds so it's like i'm like yeah
i'm like an athlete wait whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa hold the [ __ ] phone
you're six feet tall yeah i'm like
300 pounds yeah i'm like i play semi-pro
volleyball that's like in basketball
yeah
so yeah so i'm like i did not see that
one coming you are six feet tall for
real
yeah yeah oh my god jesus
when i hear like girls like wait like
i'm like like when i hear like 120 i'm
like i would never in a mil i mean maybe
some six foot girl can but not
six feet tall you gotta be one eight you
gotta be 170 180 no
yeah i wish that's like that's what i'm
trying to get to no i'm like 185. my
goal weight is 170 though so we're gonna
that's what i'm trying to get to it's
170. wow dude the most impressive number
was three dude devin i think she
deadlifts um i think she dead lifted uh
i think it was like 195. like that's not
that's that's
she's five six and i think she's like
one thirty five one good from her height
yeah that's super like because it's
different based on your height and your
weight so yeah devin is a very um devin
is gifted genetically
she dude she's hourglass shape
curves literally in all the right places
like shapely muscular legs she is
physically the strongest woman i have
ever met in my life tell me she is very
very
jesus christ six feet though she's fine
she's five six so i'm i can you know
she's still short enough not to be
taller than me when she wears heels but
wow that i did not know that about you
yeah oh my gosh that's why i'm in a
little bit of a different world because
i'm only friends with athletes but i
also have a different like because
there's a moment every year on a
volleyball or basketball team with women
like all the girls say their body counts
so i feel like i have like a decent like
wow there's no integral i swear to god
it's like a thing it's like a thing wow
all the girls will be like yeah
you might be the next uh
because you know who lavar ball is right
um
okay long story short yeah i do yeah
okay sorry guys black guy
yeah black right black guy married to a
white woman white dude his wife is six
one he's six four they made three nba
players
like there it is man and you date a
black dude now right she i'm trying to
tell you man hey y'all listen you got if
you've got those nba loins man start
popping out them kids set y'all for like
well that's the interesting cuz it's
interesting in the red pill because you
kind of have to make like um
the red pill seems to push women to make
like like to start families younger yes
uh which i i totally understand but as
like
athletes like a lot of girls go pro and
like live in europe for a couple years
that's like very typical that's a choice
you make it is a choice yeah that's what
i'm doing now that's what that's where
i'm at
but you're see you're six feet tall so
it's like
i have a friend who's six five i know a
lot of tall girls like a lot i know a
girl is six five who lisa's [ __ ]
leslie like are you famous like
or cynthia cooper like what is this
you didn't see my comment on your video
on you you had something that was like
like i can't i don't read my comments
you you liked it
that was that was what that was a
staffer that was not that was oh my god
oh my god yeah that's the listen i
haven't looked at my comments in i
haven't i haven't read my comments in
almost two years so i don't know you had
a video that was like um
it was
it said like if you're if they can't
pick up your girl and like like said and
i and i commented i was like the 6-3
girl on my volleyball team says
otherwise because i was like
i would have liked that i would have
brought i was like because some of these
girls my six five friend married to six
seven guy actually no 6 10 6 10.
so it's funny because you look at their
pictures and she doesn't even look that
tall because of course
when you meet them you're like whoa nice
to meet you yeah it was if you can't
lift up your girl like this one of you
needs to hit the gym
wow
okay well yeah six three then
listen if she's six three and she's
dating a dude that's six five he should
be able to pick her well i don't know
she's got long legs but yeah that's rare
fight air there
yeah that's not six feet tall oh my god
wow that it makes it a lot harder
it does because you guys are dealing
with 14 of dudes because you're not
trying to date a dude who's shorter than
you right yeah and it's really hard
because you're just not like really
attracted to those short it's not like
you try to be but like of course not you
can't even wear heels oh my god
no no your boyfriend's got to be over
six feet tall right yeah he is
okay yeah he's he's um he's like six
three so i'm i'm cool if they're six and
up like i'm cool if they're over six
jesus christ i'm six two devin is five
six
um why i don't think i've ever dated a
girl i don't think i've ever dated a
girl over five eight
at least not that i can remember
six feet wow like dude you're my
brother's height holy god i'm six two my
youngest brother is five eleven my
middle brother is six four so we're tall
we're tall boys
yeah no my whole family my one sister is
five ten five nine like i'm the i'm the
tallest girl so what's your last name
is your last name long is that what your
last name is no it's davis
oh okay
no
no it's funny because my dad isn't even
that tall he's 5 11. so i'm taller than
my dad listen my dad is 5 10 my mom is 5
2. i don't know how they created three
boys that are six feet tall
really yeah yeah oh my god all three of
us look exactly like our father well
actually no all three yes well me and my
brother my middle brother me and him we
look like our mother my youngest brother
looks like our father
my two sisters
look like my look like my father so
so we forgot about one of the daughters
the ho what was the what was the twenty
what were the stats for the last
daughter the 25 year old hoe no kids
just to go how would you
yeah just you know and like very i don't
know maybe known in your hometown i
don't know
um
so would you tell her to come home or
would you say give it away to the
streets and see who's the best
well as my daughter i want the best for
you let's call her haley right okay
okay haley um your twin sister debbie is
still a virgin
she's moving in here with us to make
sure that you know she finds a high
value guy but you've you've had fun with
all these guys in town
what would i advise her to do one of
them might marry your sister
oh my god dude
just playing just playing keep going
what i would advise my 25 year old um my
25 year old ho uh of a daughter to do
she'd have to move like she would have
to she'd have to change locations um
because once your reputation is that the
world is large the country is
is
the country's huge let's just say for
example we live even let's just say we
live right there in the in the central
united states like we live somewhere in
texas you can go as far west as
california or as far east as new york no
one's know who the hell you are out
there so what you need to do uh i forgot
what name i gave her uh but haley
haley what yeah haley you need to shut
down all of your social media accounts
okay shut down all your social media
accounts um and move move to one move to
one of the coasts now here's what i will
tell her
you are going to have to refrain from
being a hoe if you wanna hide and i'll
tell her look haley if you move to a big
city sleeping around is gonna look a lot
more exciting and it is
you should know but what's more
fulfilling in the long run and i know
your sister debbie asks you all about
your adventures i don't want you talking
to debbie at all
you want i want you to tell debbie that
you regret your decisions the reason why
you're moving all the way the hell out
to california is because you know that
no one here in texas is going to marry
hero ass right
but but all jokes may be aside
as i'll let her know is like you need
you need to move clear on all your
social media make friends but you're
gonna have to show a little bit of
restraint you can't
do not get the same reputation there as
you are here otherwise you're gonna have
to move again and again and again next
thing you know you're 35 years old and
when you're a 35 year old woman who just
moved to a new town let's say oh
las vegas and nobody knows you
men who have experience with women we're
going to assume that you got up to some
pretty shady [ __ ] like [ __ ] around so
this is your one second chance you're
still young you're still pretty
you need to do away with those hotel why
can't i live here with you you can but
everybody knows you're a hoe haley
i mean
you're my kid but that's i love you i
want the best for you
so what do you think because it's
interesting because one thing i hear in
the manosphere is like
making you make the next guy pay a
higher price than the last guy
so would you say that like telling that
girl like the girl who slept around with
everyone your 25 year old daughter to
make the next guy wait right like here
therefore making him pay a higher price
for the used car than the last guy who
got it immediately oh yes and so you
would tell her to do that yes listen
okay interesting dude oh yeah dude i
dude i would tell a random if a random
woman on the street came to me donovan
sharp what advice would would you give
me
never ever ever tell a guy what your
body count is never if he asks you you
[ __ ] lie your you lie your ass off
because if you tell him the truth
because you want to be open and honest
you're out now if you want to tell in
your body count of seven that's all well
and good but your personality and your
characteristics are going to have to
match that of a woman who has a seven
body count because women who have a body
count of 77 have a very difficult time
acting like they only have a body count
of seven and men with my kind of
experience we can pick up on the 77 body
count a lot quicker than the seven body
count so
lie your ass off about your body count
but you got to remember
if you're gonna lie about that body
count you need to start adopting habits
and traits that are indicative of a
woman with a low body count
it's interesting
guys but then you're posting booty pics
on instagram yeah you've got you have
pictures with rappers and athletes no no
you haven't bought one of seven last
week so it's interesting because you
almost like tell the girl to be what you
tell the guys to sniff out for
yeah
so you just tell both of them to like
play the game
yeah that's so interesting okay really
well now i don't tell guys to fake the
funk
um no but you tell them this is how you
can figure out if she's a hub like
basically you say you say all that
and so you would like you would
basically tell the girl
to like be cut like to like how to trick
the guys because i wouldn't tell them
how to trick the guy because i mean i
wouldn't tell them okay you don't want
to stay away from this and that and the
other
girls and again
like if i were to teach a class that's
very interesting so if i were to teach a
class how to hide your body count by
donovan sharp
um
dude there would be there would be so
many things that i could that i would
point out but let's just say it was a
three-pronged course um
uh uh clean up your social media
um jesus christ if you have uh
uh
piercings take them out if you have a
tattoo i'm sorry for you you got a high
body count that is that is the one thing
i'm glad my mom never let me get is a
tattoo i am so she i when i was your
mother was a wise person i never okay i
don't think i ever would have gotten it
because i'm just kind of indecisive but
like sometimes
no no i'm not going to i'm definitely
not now but like when i was younger i
definitely thought about it because all
my friends were like getting tattoos
like you know when you hit like 18 yeah
not all i don't want to say all of them
but like i don't know like a couple you
know like i'd say like half and half
maybe but like yeah i'm so glad ellie
sorry my dog is like um what kind of dog
you have i'm an english bulldog oh wow
okay we got a couple of cavalier king
charles spaniels so
um
but yeah so i'm so glad she never let me
get a tattoo because i
i think that all of my friends tattoos
like
don't look good now like to be honest
and it's only been like five years too
oh yes listen it's dead listen it's a
dead giveaway listen if you want to if
if if a girl came up to me and said
donovan how do i take myself off the
market for the highest value guys get a
tattoo that's the pink get a tattoo and
you're out you will you will never have
to worry about well i got rappers and
athletes in my dms trust me girl they're
looking to give you the d not the c not
the commitment your mother was very very
wise to tell you not to get a tattoo
yeah she oh my gosh and i was like
i was so mad too not even because i
really wanted a tattoo that bad but i
was more like why are you like judging
like these people
like you know like i don't know when
you're 18 and emotional like that's just
what you do you know argue with your mom
over
something that's not going to matter in
10 minutes anyway all right yeah
yeah that's your mom your mom did you
right
um
so that's but you so
that's so interesting that
okay so i just tell women listen i tell
you
if you're gonna lie about your body
count you have to make sure that your
actions and behaviors match your story
because if a girl slept with 150 guys
which is entirely possible and likely
these days
and you tell a guy you slept with 10
guys dude you're not
you got to be a you got to be [ __ ]
houdini you have to be able to mimic the
behaviors of a woman who has only slept
with 10 guys a woman who's been pounded
out by 150 guys she's not capable of
acting like a woman who's only slept
with 10 guys it's not in her i agree
you just can't do it yeah no i agree if
you want the so now this comes to
responsibility let's say a girl slept
with 25 guys right that's a lot of
[ __ ] dudes but
she wants to be a little more honest
okay i've slept with 15 guys now a girl
with a 25 body account who who rev who
uh who says she slept with 15 now the
distance there that's that's a little
easier to make up if she slept with 10
guys she could say maybe she slept with
five guys you can make that up but if
you sleep if you tell a guy you slept
with five guys and you slept with 155
guys that's not happening that that
that's that's too funny i think hold on
i did a poll on my like because i asked
on i think i got a decent amount of
votes i said
if you had to guess what is the average
body count for a 27 year old in 2021 75
and i said this is not based on data but
what you've experienced in the dating
world because if you look it up it's
like
i think seven or ten or something like
that
like no like if you google like like
surveys yeah that's what oh my god dude
um now unfortunately i did not specify
um
male to female i wish i did i did not oh
my god uh oh well well the average 27
year old guy
i would and i think seven to ten is
probably
on the high end the average 27 year old
girl has [ __ ] a lot more than just 17
guys so 30
38 think it's below 10
and basically 30 40 50
60
like okay i can't do math but the rest
the rest think it's over god you're tall
right
yeah i know i can't math is not my thing
oh man um
yeah next time you gotta specify
um i'll put it to you this way
and here's something that a lot of
people are going to disagree with most
women have slept with more women than
most men those are the facts those are
the facts most women have fooled around
with more women than most men this is
this most virgins in this country are
men most of them are men there are so
many
millennials and gen ziers i don't even
know what the date ranges are now
there's my mathematical skill coming up
but most uh most virgins are men
it's hard for guys to get laid getting
laid for girls is it's
it's very very easy yeah and when you
take when you when you when when you
give a young attractive woman women
choices
she's going she's going to gorge on
herself so when i hear a survey that
says well the average 27 year old woman
i slept with seven to 10 guys that's
[ __ ]
they actually say the average girl's
body count is lower than guys according
to like
but
are you serious no i'm scared hold on
hold on wait a minute hold on hold on
let me qualify that for you the average
female's body count is lower than the
average male's body count i guess we're
talking about all ages right from age
zero all the way up to a hundred maybe
but really in the age of majority sexual
maturity dude girls are out here getting
ran through man dudes are dude
oh my god
like my little like because i have
younger like siblings
and i see yeah because i'm i'm the i'm
the second of six
well sort of i have i've i have ten
siblings total oh wow i grew up with six
in the house it's kind of a long story
um but some of them were adopted like
later like after i left so but like out
of the six i was the second okay so yeah
so your parents are good people all
right
the best people i've ever met in my life
dude for your parents okay well this
makes a lot of sense yeah like you are
because adoption is a thankless oh my
god wow okay so they adopted teenagers
do you ever see the blind side
that same thing happened to us
oh my god like they took in a teenage
boy who was homeless at um
at my brother's school
and he like um
yeah he was homeless and then he
he wasn't as good a football no league
you know like the movie but but yeah
this he's not playing right tackle for
the denver broncos
no no he they took him in at 16 they
took in like
my oldest sister she's like 42 now she's
old but like when they were in their
early 20s they adopted her when she was
15 like they yeah like so that's why i
say i grew up with six because like my
oldest sister was way up she moved out
when i was one you know let me just let
me just say this pearl you are extremely
fortunate to have been raised by the
people you were raised by i'm so lucky
because you don't i can't even yeah i
mean that's that's incredible okay all
right well
yeah my parents
i don't like i'm not even trying to like
brag or like nobody like that's a good
thing
my
they're like the best people i know like
genuinely and that's
attractive to dudes who are six to and
above you guys watching what you guys
watching
that those these are the kinds of like
knowing these knowing these things about
a woman's family that makes you much
more attractive on the dating market
especially to tall guys i mean listen
well high value guys tall guys whatever
the case may be
you didn't you were not raised in chaos
you weren't raised by a single mom you
were raised by people who adopted
teenagers before they had kids of their
own
i will say my mom was not i would say
traditional like i would say she was
more of like a working mom than like a
traditional like like the ideal it seems
like in the vanosphere
um because she like she worked for me
she did work for like um my dad though
so i guess that's more yeah yeah that's
that would be yes that will that me and
my girlfriend have that relationship she
works for me so
yeah wow um
so anyway so uh getting back so you're
the you're the the second of you're the
second of six yeah yeah okay i forgot i
like
i got soft uh sorry i get so off topic
sometimes
i'm like what was i even talking about
the second of six
i think you were talking about i think
you were talking about maybe a uh a big
family and i think before then we were
talking about we encourage we encourage
women to start families young
yeah um
oh my god i don't i'm sorry it's gone i
don't remember
that's fine um
the oh we're talking about body counts
too oh yes 27
yeah look man sleeping around for girls
is
it's easier oh no i said that more women
have have hooked up with more women than
most men
and that might be
something provocative and hot taking but
you think about all of the experience
you think about all the the sexual
experience the average woman has
compared to the average man
and it's it's it's just not close that's
just the way that's just the way the
culture is today who knows 50 years from
now it might be the opposite but that's
the way it is oh i was talking about my
younger siblings how the younger
generation is like crazier than i
thought because i have
like my brother's like
like he's pretty tall and like i would
say like like girls tend to like like
him
and i'm i'm just i'm like oh my god
these women are wild and like
well
the reason why they're the reason
they're wilding is because that's their
those are their those are their
biological markers coming out they're
like ooh tall guy tall strong offspring
etc that's why they throw themselves at
him
yeah oh my gosh they do and he oh my
gosh
he lived in a multi-million dollar
mansion by himself for like a year
like like on florida in the beach
oh so his body dude his body counts
easily into the hundreds dude he might
have he might have a couple of kids out
there running around that he might not
know about he might you might yeah
okay so now the next question because
i've seen different takes and by the way
is this going too long or is this still
okay no we're good okay um i'm good for
another 20 minutes 20 minutes okay um so
the other thing that i was going to ask
how long would you tell those girls to
wait based on their situations
hmm
for sex
yeah yeah um so my 30 year old oh my god
my 30 year old single mom daughter
of two how long to wait
god
okay
so
what i would tell what i would tell my
oldest uh my oldest daughter like
oh what i would tell my favorite thought
or not it's okay
is is look in terms of sex you're
the lower your value the quicker you
have to give it up the quicker you give
it up the lower your value so you have
to understand at this point if you're
gonna make a guy wait to have sex with
you it's probably not going to go well
because because if they meet because of
the kids there you go yeah
krister who is younger and childless
why is he going to stick around and
wait for the kind of sex that he gets
from you you've had so much sex you've
put out two kids already so i mean
and so i'm just i would just let her
know listen it's possible for you to
have a good relationship it's going to
be an uphill battle i wish i could
advise you on what to do i would say
honestly you know what i would tell my
30 year old single mother of two i'll be
like the only way the only chance you're
gonna be able to walk down a high value
guy you need to get yourself into the
best shape possible
that's the only way okay so you're 30
listen you're 30 you're not old
but you're still relatively young
dude
get into the best like instagram model
hot and ants and there will be some high
value men not many but there will be
some high value men will say okay she's
got a couple of kids and she is 30 32
years old but she's feminine she's
submissive you're gonna have to be all
these things and the rapper is gonna
have to be [ __ ] tight the advantage
you'll have the advantage i'll have this
is the advantage that devin has over
most girls everybody talks about devin's
eight she's 45. kevin is in better shape
than most women in this country devon at
first oh yeah better shape than the
average 25 years she's in phenomenal
shape
so that's how to even the odds i tell
the same thing to guys you want to even
the odds get into good shape so for my
31 year old my 30 year old single mother
too get yourself in great shape my 25
year old uh with the with the low body
count uh i would advise her wait until
marriage do not sleep with the guy until
until he is ready for marriage but daddy
what if he what if he says well listen
if we don't have sex now then i'm going
to leave well pumpkin then he's not
looking for marriage he's not looking
for a wife if he's not if he is going to
leave if you don't have sex with him
then he's not looking for a husband and
if even for a girl that's not a virgin
you think
if she's got a five body count and i
know she's got a five body count i'm
telling her still wait
really okay that's interesting
well remember the distance right a girl
with a five body count has a much better
chance at she has much more her
personality traits are more indicative
of the virginal girl than the girl with
a 55 body count right
okay so she slept with five guys but
she's still i mean that's still pretty
cool it's not being that's not a version
but that's different but let's say she
slept with 10 guys
and or let's say she told the guy she
slept with 10 guys but she really slept
with 75. it's going to be hard to bridge
that gap you can bridge from five to
zero right you can bridge from from
virgin to five you can't bridge from
virgin to 77. so i told her yes wait
wait wait and if he asks you hey have
you ever had sex before what do i tell
them daddy tell them you've had sex with
two men that's it matter of fact tell
them one you want to know something your
behaviors are going to be indicative of
a woman with a low body count
so he's going to say you know what i
think she's really slept with five guys
i don't think she slept with two guys
that's not going to be a deal breaker at
that point especially for high value man
i would tell her do not have sex with
him until you are married and if he
leaves because of that he's not looking
for a wife he's looking for anything um
my 16 year old daughter i i would advise
her don't give it up till you're married
period like that's it you're a 16 year
old girl when you're 18 the world's your
oyster could literally have any man you
want don't give it up until you're
married um my 25 year old ho
i would say move across the country
don't give it up until you are in a
committed relationship that's what
that's how long it's hard to wait
and then uh the 30 year old would you
just say first date go
well
man
why women are so confused because they
don't there's no conversation on like
different
strategies based on like your experience
yeah your situation and your looks to be
honest like that's because would any of
this change if your daughter's below a
five and looks oh of course it would
definitely change okay it was poor sorry
absolutely we can keep it consistent
just for the sake of like no no
here's the thing a woman is quote below
average looking if she's in great shape
guess what
she's still there's a difference between
being pretty and attractive beautiful
women are women who have beautiful
bodies and beautiful faces attractive
women are average to below average
looking women with great bodies devin is
very devin is not beautiful she's not
gonna win any beauty pageants she's very
very attractive
in the face she's probably a five and a
half maybe an adjustable six her body's
a nine she gets looks for men and women
when we go places it is what and she's
very like likable to be honest like
she's like
yeah like she's very um
like easy to talk to and i feel like
that's like that counts for something
right of course um she's very easy to
talk to she would not say the same about
me
really that's what you do for a living
because you talk to people i talk to
people that doesn't mean i'm easy to
talk to actually had to have a i had to
have a very difficult conversation with
her today as a matter of fact about
about an hour and a half before i came
on i had to have a i had to have a talk
with her nothing major it's just you
know a little bit of maintenance she'd
been slacking off in the uh
in the cleaning department and i had to
let her know hey look uh you got a great
buddy and i love you and you love me
but if you don't if you don't if if you
don't if if you want to stay in this
relationship you're going to stop being
lazy and it's not that she's a bad
person because she's been working out
like crazy her dude she's in she is in
the best shape of her life flat stomach
huge boobs shaped the whole nine and she
knows this about herself because i'm
because we're always having sex and so
in her mind this is not something she
does consciously well you know what
donovan i'm i'm giving donovan the ass
all the time and i'm looking good so i'm
going to stop cleaning no this is just a
natural progression she knows okay i've
got a little more value so maybe i'll
slack off in the cleaning department i
took a dude i took her right there i'm
sorry dev i said have a seat i said you
are slacking off us you're being [ __ ]
lazy i said listen i love you and i'm in
this for the long haul i said but if you
don't start cleaning like you're
supposed to this relationship is not
gonna work she said yes sir right away
sir
just like that
that's so cool
um
okay yeah so
it would be really interesting if you
ever put out like dating content for i
feel like if there's ever a guy in the
red pill that put out like dating
content for women i think it would do
very well like kevin samuels is one of
them and i think that's part of the
reason he blows up of course because
like i think girls are just like
confused to be honest
this is what this is what me and devin's
podcast is going to be about we are
going to give email dating advice that's
what we're going to do
listen she's going to sit right next to
me the camera is going to be on the both
of us and we are going to have
conversations about
advice i'm going to talk to the men okay
we're going to talk to the women so
that's it's going to be a lot of fun
we're going to take phone calls and
everything and look we'll have on guests
and everything you're definitely a
friend of the show and you guys like
each other so i would love to have you
on that would be great yeah i'm totally
down yeah the second tallest person on
the panel
okay guys um make sure you go subscribe
to donovan sharp's channel um you do
daily lives right i actually i'm slack
well because of my health scare my high
blood pressure and my recent bout with
covid um i'm only doing three shows a
week but i'm gonna ramp it up here in a
little bit but but i've got videos
dropping every day so okay so he does
three three shows a week um
his stuff's pretty cool it's very
red-pilled i come on sometimes so
i'll never forget that when you broke
down my once you go black you can't go
back oh my god
okay no this is and i don't think i
this is what i don't think i articulated
well
i don't feel like there are many girls
out there that have low body counts are
feminine and like in good shape so i
feel like most guys that say oh like you
can't go like once you go black you
can't go back like they will because
like most girls aren't like
sorry
oh my god
because you honestly you were confused i
was like yo look at this he really
doesn't know
it was wonderful
but thanks so much for coming on this
yeah of course of course this was a lot
of fun
guys for real go subscribe to his
channel um i will talk to you guys next
time
thanks guys